planning doesn't count planning
strategizing making ideas that doesn't
count where you're going to grow doesn't
count you got to do you got to send an
email you got to make a piece of content
you gotta post something you gotta
follow up with somebody you have to
create you got to make instead of just
living in your head right that's how you
tell the difference plan is just living
in your head model structured business
plans ideas it's amazing I love it I
could be there all day long but you
won't have any kind of impact just
staying up in here do every single day
adopt a mindset that you need to do on a
daily basis need motivation
hey it's Nina Carmichael and we make
these videos because you are the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you know you're capable of more and
you get that Push by surround yourself
with the best so today let's learn from
one of the best my husband Evan
Carmichael and his top 10 rules for
Success enjoy
rule number two stop stealing from your
ability you have Michael Jordan level
genius at something you you you are the
greatest the greatest in the world at
something
and it's probably not what your parents
did or what you went to school for
it's sitting here somewhere deep buried
and you don't believe that you can do it
but until you actually lean in on what
you have Michael Jordan ability genius
at until you actually start doing it
you'll never live the life that you're
capable of you'll you'll constantly be
doing
what other people want you to do living
up to other people's expectations
meanwhile knowing that you're capable of
more I often get into fights uh maybe
not fights discussions maybe arguments
with people about when they're making
YouTube videos for example thought
leaves I'm I'm deeply passionate about
helping more thought leaders get onto
YouTube I want to see your message out
there because I believe that your
message can change the world I think
your message can impact people's lives
of people like you who you used to be
they need to hear your message and
you're you're too scared to get it up
there and one of the biggest
complaints are one of the biggest
objections people have is well I don't
know how to edit I don't know how to
film and what they end up doing is you
spend 20 minutes making a video
recording it and then five hours editing
it
what you're doing there is training the
wrong skill
if you want to make a video like this
right
you're gonna sit in your car I'm still
just making this video off of my phone
right I just have like can you see my
glasses maybe you can see look I've got
a there we go this is cool look I've
just got a little mini handheld whatever
tripod I guess a selfie stick more like
it and and my phone that's how I'm
filming this video that's it sitting
here in the car while my wife is in
Costco shopping and getting some awesome
food for us
if you spend 20 minutes making a video
filming it recording it and then five
hours editing it
you're just training the wrong skill
you'll never get great at the thing that
you have Michael Jordan level ability at
now if you said your ambition is to be
the world's greatest editor that's
different congratulations you're doing
it you're doing it but if you want to be
a thought leader a speaker an expert you
want to you want to learn to make videos
and be the front facing person then
spending 20 minutes on something to
actually improve your skill that's
improving your skill making the video
but five hours editing it you just
not wasting time but you're you're
stealing from your opportunity
you're stealing from your ability you're
stealing from your best self
okay well what do I do Evan what how do
I how do I then create I don't want to
put up something that's bad
the thing that gets you there is
actually getting great at your skill the
Michael Jordan level skill
I'd rather you spend five hours
making a video doing it again and again
and again and again and again and again
and again so that you don't need editing
that you're so good at the thing that
you don't need editing
because that's a skill that will serve
you for life
because when you go on stage
you don't get to edit yourself right
there's no second takes when you go on
TV and you're being interviewed when you
go on people's podcasts you're being
interviewed if you're you're teaching
yourself that you're only good when
you're edited
and that's not your Michael Jordan level
ability rule number three have a balance
this whole seriousness versus playful
thing I agree that it's important to be
playful I think smiling is great I think
having a happy optimistic positive way
of thinking about things is really
important especially as entrepreneurs
because we have to deal with so much
crap and so much pain so much misery so
much rejection so much other people's
negativity around us that if you are not
playful if you are not joyous then it's
really really hard to keep going on your
mission and it's ultimately why a lot of
people stop and they quit they get
consumed by the negativity and they have
to leave it and go off and do something
else that being said I also think
there's a time for seriousness I think
it can really help you I think it can
help Focus you I think it can help drive
you forward on your mission the way I
see playfulness and seriousness are two
sides of the same coin I think you need
both I think they're not opposite of
each other I think they complement each
other I see it as the same thing as
ambition and gratitude I think you need
to be really ambitious I think it's
important to have big goals and set a
life for yourself that you want to go
off and accomplish and keep striving to
do it and I think it's important to be
really grateful for everything that you
already do have you are spoiled you are
lucky you are so fortunate just to be
alive just to be living in your country
just be able to watch these YouTube
videos there's so much that you have to
be grateful for that you don't even
recognize and so I think both of those
serve each other I think if you are just
overly ambitious and never are grateful
I think it just leads to a really dark
place I think it's never enough and it
just becomes all-consuming and I think
if you're only grateful all the time and
have zero ambition then that's a happy
life but you're not helping others
you're not serving others you're not
fulfilling the potential that you have
inside yourself and so I think of them
as both being necessary I think you need
both of them I think one Standalone
doesn't help you get to where you need
to go and so I see that as the same
thing as playfulness and seriousness I
see them as two sides of the same coin I
think you need both of them at different
times to help you go off and be that
best version of yourself rule number
four do what matter
so thinking about okay I'm not great at
these things
but they need to get done
right some of these things have to get
done first you want to eliminate if it's
if you don't have to do it then don't do
it this there's some things that you're
doing that actually don't matter
there's something that I'm doing that
don't matter that you think matter but
then when you analyze like that doesn't
even matter nobody even cares if I do
that thing or not
right just eliminate it don't don't give
it to somebody else if it shouldn't even
be done in the first place you eliminate
it
then you automate it so automate is look
for ways to do it through software
through technology through tools
anything that I'm I'm doing multiple
times like okay how do I
how do I make this more automatic so
that I don't have to be doing this all
the time
and if you can't eliminate it and you
can't automate it then you delegate it
and delegate is you give it to somebody
give it to somebody who that's their
Michael Jordan level genius
editing these videos I have an amazing
team you know Christina hi Christina is
amazing and that's her Michael Jordan
level genius she makes amazing videos
she can edit way way way better than I
ever could let alone than what I can do
right now
and when you find people who they are
the Michael Jordan level of the thing
that you suck at that's when you can
really start to explode now you might be
you might not be able to afford them yet
so what can you do well one you get
people who can volunteer who can maybe
do some kind of barter like
entrepreneurship is about being
resourceful
what can you offer them and what can
they offer you what kind of trade can
you make if you have no money what kind
of trade can you make instead of saying
well I just I don't have money to hire
somebody so I'm just going to do it
myself you have to start being more
strategic
you have to start thinking okay what am
I what am I so fantastic at what is your
Michael Jordan level ability and how can
that be of value to somebody else that
in exchange for me helping them they can
help me with this thing
that's how entrepreneurship works
the ones who really really win they're
not the ones who do it all themselves
they're the ones who are resourceful to
find ways to bring on a team
right the ones who are Ultra successful
are not doing everything themselves they
they're willing to go and do it if they
have to
they're willing to do it if they have to
but they're not default thinking I'm
going to do everything myself
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five schedule due time
schedule your
do what I want you to do is plan for one
hour every single day if you're an
entrepreneur one hour every day where
you are doing pick a time ideally I
think morning like if you get in at nine
to nine to ten first hour of the day but
if it's not then block any account this
is important
this is what will change your life this
is what will change the trajectory of
your business if you are stuck
constantly just responding to people and
planning perfectionist mode do time
right we said do it daily point number
one now you gotta schedule it in just
have an intention won't do anything if
you're not actually taking action on it
right you're not doing the thing that
you promise to do you're not doing the
doing the progress that you will make
the closer you get to your goals will be
a reflection of what you are putting in
your calendar what you're actually doing
so I want you to schedule one hour today
of due time every single day we're going
to be making something and pushing it up
to the world rule number six be grateful
you can't feel grateful and sad at the
same time you can't feel grateful and
upset at the same time you can't at the
same time feel grateful and hurt
vengeful rage you can't gratitude is the
opposite emotion the opposite expression
of all of those things so whenever
you're feeling low down negative hurt
upset the answer is gratitude
I don't like staying in
negative emotions for too long the only
one is grief you know I think the only
one that I
let happen is grief because I think you
just have to work your way through it I
don't want to trick myself out of grief
because
you're feeling it for a reason I don't
actually think it's a negative emotion I
think you have to just work your way
through it but everything else upset
anger hurt jealousy rage think about all
the other negative emotions that you
experience I don't want to stain them
for too long they don't serve me they
don't serve you they don't allow you to
show up as your best self and so the
fastest way out is gratitude because
there's always something that you can't
be grateful for it's just a perspective
shift if I was sitting here in the car
feeling upset or feeling sorry for
myself or down on myself uh I can always
think back to man I used to make 300
bucks a month and feel like I wasn't
doing anything
that I was bringing no value that wasn't
contributing anything
and now I get the I get to sit in this
car I get to sit in this car
right that little shift can make all the
world of difference I was talking to
Jeremy yesterday on my team and Jeremy
is an entrepreneur invested into
what 18 months ago I guess he used to
have a job working at a grocery store
hating his life knowing who's capable of
more earning minimum wage
and just not liking what he was doing at
all and now he's he's built over half a
million dollar business a year
doing YouTube Consulting based off of
what I teach them teach them taught him
taught him and continue to teach him you
know he's got a half a million dollar
plus business now and we're talking
yesterday and it was a little down
because
you know there's a client who left him
and and that happens right any client
service business you get bad news
clients believe you you will at some
point underperform you will disappoint
people that's gonna happen and that and
my job is to help give more perspective
to say dude
it's okay you're you're still great
look at what you've built in the past
the 18 months look at where you were it
used to be a grocery store clerk now
you're working with amazing people
helping them build their channels
getting paid insane amounts of money
compared to what you're used to like how
much money do you have in your bank
account compared to where you were 18
months ago how much more fulfilled are
you in the work that you're doing right
now compared to where you used to be 18
months ago right how much of your world
has changed so don't get too down
because the down doesn't serve you rule
number seven be honest most people can't
handle radical honesty we can't handle
it because we're too caught up in other
people's opinions we care too much about
what other people think about us we're
so insecure that if you actually got
honest feedback you'd feel like
you suck as a human not that you just
have an area that you need to work on we
can't separate between
skills that we need to work on and us
the fact that we suck at a skill we
interpret as we suck as a human because
we care too much about other people
think which is why radical honesty is
not something that we generally lead
with but until you get to the point
where you can have that both with
yourself and at least with the closest
people around you until you get there
you won't have fulfilling deep
meaningful honest relationships when I
think about radical honesty I think
about it in two ways one of giving it be
able to give honest feedback and then be
able to receive it two different sides
of the coin that I'm going to break down
on this video so in terms of giving it
we would love to be able to give more
honesty back right how many people in
your life would you love to have a more
honest conversation with and tell them
what's really on your mind you don't
because you're afraid of how they're
going to react you're afraid that
they're gonna
get hurt they're going to freak out
they're going to judge you more they're
gonna they're gonna run away whatever
you're afraid you're afraid of the
reaction and so the way around that is
to show love
when you give honest feedback to
somebody the initial reaction is
negative because they feel judged
that's really at the core of it like
they feel that you are judging them they
don't feel the love so you have to leave
with love
the more that they feel loved that then
you give the feedback they know it's
coming from a loving place they're much
more receptive rule number eight release
imperfect things get used to releasing
imperfect things it doesn't mean that
you settle for crap
that's not the message it's not just
okay this sucks so we're going to
release it and not care about it anymore
by releasing the perfect things though
and then tweaking it and getting better
you're getting used to doing you're
getting used to not just holding on to
your perfect Concepts and perfect dreams
forever for me an example could be to
make make imperfect videos you know do
Instagram stories and if I make a
mistake I post it if I make a mistake I
try to make it into into something fun
when I was in Boston I was trying to say
we're gonna go see some dim sum we're
going to a dim sum restaurant and say
we're gonna go to dim dim dim sum right
I stumbled on my words and I made into
something fun and I released it like yes
that's the best put that out there
perfectionists need to get used to
losing the perfectionist habit
and it won't ever go away that's always
the it's always the big fear that I
don't want to become a slob I don't want
to let myself go I don't want to release
garbage out to the you won't you'll
never be that person you'll never stop
caring
but you just need to lose the
perfectionist habit a little bit
because you will never be perfect
the stuff you release will never be
perfect you will always look back at
what you made and say it could be made
better and that's awesome that's your
greatest strength but it's also your
greatest vulnerability it's your
greatest weakness so getting used to
once a week releasing something that
isn't perfect
it's the best that you can make within
the time allotted once a week every week
release that within your own industry so
for me be making a video do a Snapchat
story for me it's daily three to five
times a day but at least once a week and
when it sucks when you made a mistake
when you want to delete it when you want
to say of course they can't post that I
can't sell that I can't put that out
there as soon as you're about to hit the
delete button boom that's when you post
it and feel the fear and the nervousness
and the craziness and like oh my gosh I
can't believe I just did that that
sucked and then release it
so you know what that wasn't actually
that bad like what's the response it's
not not actually that bad and when you
can get used to releasing imperfect
products and keep your drive to make
perfect products that's when ultimately
you will win to move from planning mode
into the doer mode rule number nine have
Big Dreams people will not understand
what you're trying to do if you are an
entrepreneur with a big dream a big
mission a big Vision some big goals for
yourself people won't understand
what you're trying to do if everybody
understands you're thinking way too
small if everybody's like yeah that
makes a lot of sense yeah oh that that's
exactly like this you're thinking too
small your potential your vision is
bigger than how you're explaining it
at the beginning it should be difficult
for people to wrap their head around
what you do it should be difficult to
explain who you are if somebody asks you
at a networking event or some party hey
what do you do I think it should be
difficult for you to explain who you are
I think that's fantastic I think that
means you're actually living your life
instead of living inside some box that
is easy to understand I look at my
history and I've been on YouTube since
2009 my first video and at the time
YouTube was not what it is today it was
not an educational platform there
weren't really people doing entrepreneur
videos
educational videos long form videos it's
just a totally different beast and it
took five years to get the 7 000
subscribers on my main channel five
years seven thousand subscribers
I remember one of the videos that
I loved the most
I was so proud I spent the most amount
of effort and collaboration time in
creating this video
and it was it was a long video it was
six minutes
six minute video back in the day so this
is long video and I showed it to
somebody when I was basically ready to
release it I showed it to somebody who
was in the industry who's not in the
YouTube industry but in the in the video
industry and
I showed it to him and I said hey what
do you think like I'm I'm pretty happy
with this video do you have any thoughts
feedback suggestions and he just didn't
want me to publish it he said nobody's
going to watch a video that's six
minutes long nobody but just it's just
way too long nobody's gonna watch it he
told me that I didn't understand how the
internet worked
uh and just I don't know just poured
into me I shared some of the exact
quotes in in year one word my first book
of what of what he said to me and he was
an expert right he was somebody who was
it wasn't just some guy off the street
he was a guy who was in thought
leadership did a lot of video content
and him telling me that this would never
work and it was too long that I didn't
understand how things work and a younger
you know less experienced Evan might
have listened to him
but at the time I felt okay I don't know
maybe he's right but I spent a lot of
time on this thing and I liked it
it moved me it inspired me so whatever
I'll just post it who cares if it ends
up being a giant flop then lesson
learned maybe it'll inspire you know a
couple hundred people and
I had fun doing it right and so we
released it and at the time my best
video had a hundred thousand views in a
year and I was so proud of that video
man a hundred thousand hundred thousand
views in a year that's awesome
this video launched and I did a hundred
thousand views in a month
it ended up being my best video on the
channel it's not anymore but was the
best bit of my channel for maybe a
couple years
uh now it's got you know a couple
million views on it and it's just a
reminder that I'm trying to do something
big rule number 10 the last one before
our very special bonus clip change your
environment you are where you are
because of your environment the easiest
way to change where you are right now
and if you're not happy you want to
change where you are right now in life
the easiest way to do it is to change
your environment change who you hang out
with change the videos that you watch
change what you wear change where you go
change your habits when you change your
environment it automatically triggers
new thoughts new beliefs new mindsets
inside you where if you hang out with
the people who are not living the life
that you want you're watching the videos
of people who are tearing each other
down instead of educating and lifting
people up when you're constantly
surrounded by negativity and
small-mindedness guess what you become
if you can switch it if you can choose
consciously to make a change in your
environment towards a better life that
life will start to manifest
so when I was on my tour in 2019 it was
the first time I got to meet John
ashtraf I was going to San Diego and
John's team heard that I was doing my
tour and said hey if you're coming to
San Diego would you like to interview
John for your Channel
uh yeah yeah yes I would yes I would
like to do that very much how do we make
that happen and uh we we scheduled it it
was not part of my initial tour uh we
had to move things around to make that
happen and we had the fortune to spend I
don't know half of a day with John we
went to his office
a Nero gym we did the interview we hung
out we talked about YouTube uh met his
team and there's the knowledge exchange
which is great where I got to ask some
questions and hang out and we we I don't
know how long we spent there on the
actual interview but more important is
the energy exchange more important is
when you're hanging around somebody
who's accomplished a lot it it makes you
want to do more you know when you're
around people who are more fit than you
it makes you want to be more fit when
you're around people who have a great
relationship it makes you want to have a
better relationship when you're around
people who've had success in business it
makes you want to have more success in
business and the challenge and a big
reason why I make all of my content is
because
you are probably the most ambitious
person that you know you're the most
ambitious positive happy uplifting
person in your circle and that's
fantastic and that's a gift that you
give to other people because you're
encouraging to lifting them up but
there's nobody pulling you forward
there's nobody who you're hanging out
with who says you could be doing more
and so hanging out with John Ashraf and
at his place in San Diego was another
extra push it's like this is
this is something that I want more of
these are the people that I want to hang
out more with even though I'm
introverted and shy and don't like to
introduce myself to people and think
that I suck at networking uh
it's still important to spend as much
time as possible with the people who
inspire you to live a better life
whatever that version of your life is
I'd encourage you to look at your your
calendar look at your schedule look at
what you're doing right now look at how
you're spending your time
much of it is actually dedicated to the
thing that you could be the greatest in
the world at
and for too many people it's it's not
enough for too many people it's zero
you have ideas and hopes and dreams and
Ambitions and goals but there's nothing
in your calendar where you're actually
spending time focused on it
the best thing you can do to set you up
for a life of Happiness fulfillment
purpose income all of it is to
drastically change what's in your
calendar
to spend more time developing your
Michael Jordan level skill ability
genius you have the power to control
your world how you think how you act
your mindset with the words that you
speak when you use weak language you
signal to yourself that you are weak you
signal to yourself that your goals
aren't important you signal to yourself
that you are not worth it you lose
respect for yourself and the people
around you don't respect you either we
need to stop using weak language and pay
attention to the words that you're
speaking to others and to yourself now
this is not an easy task because most of
the words that you're using the way that
you talk to others into yourself you're
on autopilot you're on cruise control it
just happens you've been doing this for
years or decades and so switching it is
not going to happen overnight but if you
pay attention to the next three things
that I'm gonna share with you it can
have a dramatic impact on your
self-confidence on the goals that you
have for yourself and on the outcomes
you create for yourself in the world
let's do it number one I can't I'm not I
don't what you say after those three
things shapes your identity it speaks to
how you think and speak about yourself
so I can't I can't be an entrepreneur I
can't be a leader I can't be a YouTuber
I can't I can't I can't I can't I can't
especially this one when you say I can't
pay very very very very very very very
close attention to what follows and try
and try and try to shift it from I can't
to either I choose not to or I can't yet
I'm not I'm not a good salesperson I'm
not funny I'm not the kind of person who
follows through again pay close
attention and try to shift it to not yet
I don't
I don't program I don't know how to make
money I don't think like that switch I
don't to I don't yet I can't I'm not I
don't those statements are final those
statements don't allow for growth those
statements are how you feel about
yourself and don't allow for the stretch
they don't allow you to get better and
so either eliminate them from your
vocabulary or change them to yet number
two is catch your cruise control the way
that you have been speaking about
yourself the way that you have been
talking to yourself has been happening
using the same words for years maybe
even decades it's so automatic for you
you are on cruise control you are on
autopilot you think small and talk
negatively about yourself without even
thinking about it you need to catch your
cruise control and listen don't be too
hard on yourself this is so ingrained
these patterns have been around for so
long you are just Auto defaulting to
cruise control that most of these times
you will not even catch it you will not
catch 99 of these moments of these words
of these languages that you're using for
yourself but if you have the awareness
if they have the intention if you have
the desire every now and then you will
catch it another quick hack is to enlist
the friend and list the people around
you your wife your husband your team
your kids kids especially my son Hayden
loves calling me out on things enlist
their help tell them this is where I
want to play a bigger game this is where
I'm frustrated with myself this is where
I keep talking badly about myself and
putting myself down these are the words
the language that need to change and
every time you hear me talking this way
I need you to bring it to my awareness
and let me know because I want to catch
my cruise control for me personally it's
around complaining anytime I complain I
want my wife I want my team I want my
son I want the people around me to say
Evan you are complaining right there
that was a complaint eat it right I'm
happy for them to hug me with it to yell
at me with it I just want them to let me
know now when I told everybody they said
listen you you barely complain you're
like the least complaining person that
we know awesome thank you I'm humbled
but I still complain and I probably
complain a lot and a lot of the times
I'm missing it and so please please
please please please please please
please please please even if you think
I'm great at it if you catch me
complaining I want you to call me out on
it so enlisting your friends can be
really helpful because you will likely
not catch most of them yourself but it's
imperative that you start working on
catching your cruise control step number
three is manual override you have caught
your cruise control you have found the
autopilot it's about to happen again
this negative talk that you're about to
speak out into the world about yourself
or your ideas you putting yourself down
is about to come out again or has just
come out what do you do about it because
this is really important
if you catch yourself playing smaller
talking negatively about yourself if you
catch it and you don't do anything it
actually makes it worse it's better that
you don't even catch it at all if you
catch it and you recognize I am playing
small right now and you ignore it and
you don't change your behavior you are
building that identity for yourself that
you are somebody who is playing small
you are consciously building that
identity for yourself and you need to
stop it it makes it worse
where when you do catch it
when you find yourself falling into
those patterns those behaviors that you
don't want anymore whether you find it
yourself or somebody's calling you out
on it what do you do you need to kick
your manual override into action and
take the action that you want because
that starts building the positive habit
that starts building the positive
respect this is how you build respect
for yourself this is how you start
building the muscle
this isn't just a zero-sum game this
isn't just we go back to neutral when
you catch it you either go sliding down
or you go propelling up the choice is
yours when you catch yourself playing
small when you catch yourself coming off
of cruise control
you have to do the thing that builds the
self-respect up and speak positively
about yourself and do the thing that you
are scared to do most entrepreneurs
aren't patient enough most entrepreneurs
end up losing their business they end up
shutting down because they think it's
going to happen in a couple months or
even six months or a year and really
it's going to take them four years five
years before they hit their Mark they
don't have enough patience they don't
allow enough time for momentum to build
up and they quit and they end up going
back to a crappy job that they hate and
maybe never ever take a shot and get an
entrepreneurship because I feel it's not
for them or really they missed out you
missed out on your destiny you missed on
creating something amazing
because you just didn't have enough
patience now I believe in patients in
the macro I believe in patients and
knowing it's going to take a long time I
also think inpatients can serve you
greatly but that's in the micro that's
in the daily the impatience of did I do
my best today did I do my best today can
I do better can I drive more can I drive
harder and knowing that even if I give
my best every single day it's still
going to take time
it's still going to take a number of
years for something to happen I want it
to happen as soon as possible I'm going
to drive and be impatient as crazy to
get it going but I know it's going to
take time too it's embracing both that's
when you start to win I look at my my
YouTube my Instagram my social media
strategy YouTube 7
000 subscribers four years ago 1.2
million subscribers now four years by
making videos every day every day and
I'm impatient as anything because I want
it to be amazing I want to make every
video better than the last and looking
for all the hacks and SEO and thumbnail
strategies and title strategies and all
of the stuff that we're supposed to do
right I'm on top of it and I know that
it's going to take me four years to get
there I know it's going to take me a
while to get to my next 2 million five
million 10 million I look at Instagram
follow me on my Instagram Journey I'm
starting from nothing you can see how to
build it up from zero I had eight
thousand followers many of you already
have more followers than I do on
Instagram but I'm gonna win I'm gonna
pass people I'm gonna get mine because
I'm gonna make daily consistent content
three to four times a day for four years
I'm gonna be impatient as anything and
that the post today has to be amazing
has to be something that I want to show
my grandkids right that's the intent
every time I create anything I want my
grandkids to watch this video I want
grandkids to watch the next Instagram
thing that I put up it's the best that I
can come up with in the moment and I
know it's going to take me four years
maybe three years maybe two years but
it's not gonna take me two months
I realize it's going to take working
hard and working smart together always
you need to hustle while you wait if you
can embody this advice and apply it to
your business on a day-to-day basis this
will be the biggest momentum shift in
your company this will move you so close
to your goals at an incredible Pace that
is unbelievable just most people don't
do it hustle while you wait listen with
every goal that you have it relies on
other people you need other people to be
a part of your process right if you're
selling to customers you need the
customer to say yes they have to make
their decision there's a bunch of back
and forth if you're waiting on a product
to come you're waiting on your supplier
to come forward this there's always
things that are outside your control
that you're waiting other people for and
yes when it comes to you you want to get
it done as soon as possible if a
customer is asking for a quote you want
to get it off your plate ASAP you should
not be the bottleneck in momentum
happening in your business that's a
whole other problem as soon as that
comes to you it's getting taken care of
and you're building momentum but you're
still even at the most Peak efficiency
waiting for other people
to take action that's gonna happen so
what do you do in those moments you
hustle you build new momentum you build
new clients you build new relationships
you maintain the existing ones and get
everything done as soon as possible and
then in the downtime while you're
waiting for a decision you're not just
twiddling your thumbs you're not just
sitting on the couch you're not watching
Netflix you're off hustling new business
quick example I was doing a photo shoot
with Richard this guy's celebrity
photographer he's done Lady Gaga done
the whole bunch of rappers he came over
and we did a photo shoot together and in
between his shots he's got to set up
lights he's gotta get his fog machine
going he's got to get the right angle
he's got to set up the green screen and
so when he needs me I'm there I'm ready
I'm posing I'm in action I'm ready to go
but there's a lot of setup in between
shots and so what am I doing I'm pulling
up my phone and I'm responding to you
guys I'm making videos I'm doing
responses I'm getting on Twitter on
Instagram I'm doing on Snapchat I'm I'm
sending out video responses to you guys
I'm working I'm hustling on my down time
while I'm waiting for Rich for this
project I am hustling connecting with
you guys and that's the approach that
you need to take people say well how do
I find the time to respond to people on
social media I probably have a way
bigger accounts than you guys do and I
find the time because I make the time in
between the other things that I'm doing
this is so critical people are losing so
much time the answer is not to wake up
two hours earlier and think that's going
to solve your problem the answer is
you're losing time every single day you
are leaking valuable time from your
daily schedule and so I highly highly
highly encourage you to take this
message home while you are working while
people are waiting on you for stuff you
are doing your best to deliver as soon
as possible so that you are not the
bottleneck in your business
but then while you're away to another
people you get your hustle on you
continue to build momentum it is such a
hack to get you closer to achieving the
goals that you have for yourself stop
sleeping while you're waiting for the
people to get back to you hustle while
you wait most of the skills that you
need to succeed are not taught in school
that's because these skills cannot be
taught from a textbook they need to be
learned by doing they involve other
people so today I'm going to give you
the three most important skills that
I've developed that if you can get out
there and start learning will transform
your business and your life skill number
one is learn to add value if you want to
have success in business or in any
relationship you need to learn the add
value you need to learn how to
understand what the people that you're
working with what they want what their
goals are you want to be their chief
goal officer be everybody's chief goal
officer you need to understand not just
what you want but what do they want what
are they trying to accomplish how can
you bring value to them how can you help
them get through whatever problem is in
front of them right now and the more you
add value the more money you're gonna
make the more Partnerships you're gonna
make the more people are going to want
to work with you talk about you be
around you because you are bringing
everybody else up skill number two is
hustle while you wait this is so
important for Success you will find this
in every single entrepreneur who has
success you hustle while you wait
there's a lot of waiting in business
there's a lot of waiting for someone to
get back to you there's a lot of waiting
for someone to sign a contract there's a
lot of waiting a lot of waiting a lot of
waiting you know on Christmas day you
might be working making videos while
other people are waiting like you're
waiting you're waiting you're waiting
you're waiting you're waiting so what do
you do while you wait you hustle you go
work on other things you start building
momentum somewhere else if you spend
your life waiting on other people and
you're not doing anything in the
meantime you will fail here's a quick
example yesterday Alex came over
yesterday was supposed to be my
mentoring day I trained Alex I work with
him I spend a couple hours with him
helping him grow trying to dance salsa
he couldn't make it in time because he
had to go to a walk-in clinic for a foot
issue great
What would most people do
most people when something gets canceled
what do you do
you go watch Netflix do you go check out
Facebook do you go consume content you
just take it as a break that's what most
people do somebody cancels on you what
do you do you take a break I deserve a
break I've been working really hard and
deserve a break
what did I do yesterday when Alex
canceled I went to work I started
getting ahead on YouTube day I started
getting ahead of my research I started
getting ahead what I had to do today
that's the key you send something out
you're waiting for a response what are
you doing while you're waiting for a
response you're hustling against 10
other people you're growing You're
Building momentum you're planning for
the future you're doing you're grinding
you're getting out there and so that's
one of the most important skills that
you can develop while you are waiting
for somebody to get back to you while
you're waiting for yes or no or your
partner to do something you are hustling
on something else you need to learn to
hustle while you wait and skill number
three is put your goals ahead of your
convenience
guys this is important your goals will
not be convenient for you you going off
and doing that thing that is different
that is outside the norm that most
people don't have success with you want
to you have the audacity to go say I
want to be successful here you're
waiting for it to be convenient for you
it will not be convenient you will have
to do things that you are uncomfortable
with you will have to grow in ways that
you'd never imagine you growing because
you have to get outside you have to go
and Chase things that are not going to
be convenient for you and so I look at
my my tour coming up as an example
probably the most common comment that I
get from people who are learning about
the tour is when are you going to come
to my city when are you going to come to
Florida when are you going to come to
London when are you going to come to New
York when are you going to come to my
city I'm not I'm not coming on this tour
I'm not maybe I come next year maybe I
never come if you're waiting for me to
come to your city for you to get the
information you need you're going to
lose
and it's not just me it's anybody else
you're waiting for Tony Robbins to come
to your city you're waiting for somebody
else to come to your city don't stop it
you're gonna lose you have to go out and
put your goals ahead of your convenience
you're waiting for it to be convenient
for you you're waiting for it to come to
you it's not you have to go out and
claim it you have to go out and make it
happen fear is normal it's part of what
makes you human you would not be human
or you'd have some crazy condition if
you never felt fear I think the people
who say Don't Be Afraid aren't giving
you practical advice
be afraid feel the fear and then step
into it and do it anyway and the more
you get used to taking on those fearful
projects that you're scared of the
stronger you'll get the more resistance
you'll get the higher tolerance you'll
get to do bigger better Bolder better
things I think the trick though is
spotting the fear
here's what I think happens to most
people there's some opportunity that
comes along
there's some moment that comes along
whether it's with a client or meeting
somebody or an event something comes
along that you're afraid of you're
afraid of doing it it's going to stretch
you beyond what you've ever done before
and then what you do is you rationalize
saying no
I don't have the money to go to that
event
I'm too busy to go and do that thing
right now you find the reason why you
can't go and do it you rationalize it
but really deep down the reason is
you're just afraid and until you spot
the fear until you understand that it's
really just the fear then you're never
going to solve the problem
so step one is understanding
when there is fear
step two is then stepping into it and
doing it anyway and a lot of this stuff
is just so subconscious you know we as
human beings are kind of trained to when
we're afraid Something's Gonna go wrong
and to be safe and so it's trying to
catch that subconscious action and
proactively change it so an example for
me when I was starting my YouTube
channel
my agent
would tell me you have to go and do
videos in public I want you to go out on
the street and make your video in public
my natural reaction
was
fear but I didn't catch it initially it
the gear won't be as good in public you
know I can't control the light settings
I'm going to be bouncing around with the
camera it's not going to be a great
experience for the people watching why
would I do that I'm rationalizing a
reason why I don't have to do it or
really I'm just afraid right you could
solve all those problems and he told me
stop being afraid and just go out and do
it you cut through it and let me see my
own fear
and so I did it and when I first went
out and filmed in public I took out it
was my phone or my camera I don't
remember and I'm walking down the street
and then the postman is there so as soon
as I see the postman
I quiet down and I can put the camera
away
just walking normally
and then when the postman leaves
I'm back to filming
and that time I noticed like I'm I'm
doing it because
I'm afraid and I got pissed okay next
time
I gotta speak up next time I gotta do
better and so I went out
and forced myself to go and do it again
and I was walking past and there were
these construction workers and instantly
again the Panic sets in like people are
watching the construction workers like I
know they don't really even care about
me and what I'm saying what's happening
on the street
but I forced myself through it
it was awkward it wasn't great I think I
had to redo it again anyway but I I took
the step
I got better at it I recognized the fear
and I jumped into it and now to the
point where I'll make videos walking on
the hall and make videos when I'm at
Disneyland Disney World you know I'll
make videos in the streets of anywhere
and there's still a moment even now
after how many videos I've done there's
still a moment of who's watching
I think it's natural normal it's not as
strong as it used to be and more
importantly it doesn't limit me from
doing the thing that I want to do
and so spotting the fear
and not rationalizing in a way and not
just doing what your subconscious always
does that keeps you down where you are
is so important
being truthful that the reason why you
said no
or you're not taking this opportunity
it's just because you're afraid and the
answer to saying no should never be
because I'm afraid
you want to re-jig your system so
whenever that's the answer because I'm
afraid to do it now you have to do it
when I was 20 years old I missed my shot
because I was scared and I vowed never
to do it again I was in Paris I was on
vacation I was in university and I'm
sitting here with my map outside your
Notre Dame cathedral in Paris and a girl
comes up and asks me for directions but
she was a French girl
and it didn't twig until later that why
would a French Grill be asking me for
directions
in English didn't really make sense
right and then I thought you know what I
should ask her out if you see what she's
doing tonight she'll take her to you
know Astro for coffee or dinner or
something see what she's up to but I was
afraid I was afraid to do it I was
afraid to do it and I let her walk away
because really was I was afraid of
rejection and As She's Walking Away the
Notre Dame is on a river and I'm on one
side of the river and she crosses over
to the other side of the river
and I was so upset at myself I was so
upset that I didn't take my shot I was
so upset that I didn't try at least try
and what I did was ended up taking a
picture
and as I took the picture she actually
walked behind one of the market stalls
and I didn't actually get her picture
it's fine so I had this beautiful
picture of this French you know
Riverside and what I did when I got home
I was still upset about it so I blew the
picture up and I put it on my wall I was
actually trying to find the picture to
show you guys but I couldn't find
anywhere in my files I blew it up though
and I put in my wall so I'm at
University I blow it up and put on my
wall everybody who walks in
asked me about the picture
and it just looks like a nice beautiful
French scene but I didn't tell anybody
what it really represented to me why it
was really so important and I looked at
that picture every day because the next
time that I had to take my shot I wanted
to go out and do it I didn't want to be
afraid I wanted to conquer my fear and
say yes
and this served me really well a year or
so later when I had to make
the really tough decision do I take this
job that I always wanted I had these
high paying job opportunities 80 to 100
000 starting salary with the companies
that I really wanted to go at or
continue with my startup that was
failing I was making 300 a month The
Logical practical safe easy thing to do
would have been to take the job it's
what I thought I always wanted so my
friends want is what you're supposed to
do coming out of University I didn't
want to live with the regret of not
knowing what happened with my business
and looking at that picture daily
reminded me to take my shot the next
time it comes around and so I gave
myself a year to say I'm going to push
off those jobs they'll still be there in
a year even if it's not those jobs it's
some other job I'm gonna give this a
shot I can deal with the failure I could
deal with the rejection I can deal with
it not working out even though that's a
really kind of short-term intense pain
when I can't deal with is there threat
of not knowing because that's not some
short-term minimal pain that's forever
if I chose not to focus on my business
and I took that job I would forever look
back on that moment and think what if
what if I just tried a little bit harder
what if I gave it a little bit more yeah
you know but it wasn't working I wasn't
getting results but what if I gave it a
little bit more I did not want to live
with that regret and I'm sure you've had
moments in your life too when you didn't
take the shot when you had an
opportunity right in front of you
and you didn't go for it
like Eminem says if you had one shot one
opportunity to seize everything you ever
wanted
would you take it
and that picture on the wall helped me
take my shot and I hope sincerely
that the next time you get your chance
at something that you don't shrink down
that you don't say no out of fear that
you don't say no because you find some
practical reason why you can't do it
that you take your shot and if you've
had those moments that you regret
where you wanted to take your shot and
you didn't
give yourself a visual reminder like I
did in my room
to say this
is not happening again
next time
I'm gonna take my shot
I hope you take yours if you are not
happy in life it's because you're not
serving enough I believe that humans are
good
99.99 of humans are good there's a tiny
little fraction of a percent of people
who enjoy giving harm and hurting others
because they have some chemical
imbalance but apart from that people are
good and we are connected to each other
your highest purpose in life will come
from helping others but the next
question becomes how how do I do it how
do I find my higher purpose how do I
know what I'm supposed to do how do I
get direction I'm going to give you the
three-step process that I call the
purpose planner that will give you the
clarity that you're looking for I break
it down into your who your why and your
how let's start with the who your who is
your one word most important core value
everybody has a core value if you're a
human being you have a core value that
you believe in more than anything else
and when you understand who you are when
you understand your single most
important core value then you're less
likely to be swayed by other people
you're less likely to live somebody
else's version of your life because they
have Clarity and you don't when you do
not have Clarity you end up chasing
everybody else's Clarity you end up
doing their version because they have
certainty and you have no idea what
you're doing it's like you're walking on
quicksand and you're constantly sinking
and you know there's something greater
for you your one word your most
important core value is the rock that
you stand on when the rest of the world
is crumbling around you so for me it's
belief I one word is belief that's what
I stand on if you love believe you're
going to be a huge fan of this channel
because I talk about it in some form in
every video every video should ooze
believe if you hate believe you're
probably gone by now you hate my channel
and that's okay go go do your thing
somewhere else you need to figure out
your who you need to figure out what
your one word most important core value
is that becomes the lens through which
you see your entire world and attracts
the goodness into your life step number
two is your why why do you do what you
do now I'm a big believer that your
purpose comes from your pain that
whatever your most painful moment was in
life whatever you struggled with the
most growing up in life whatever
moment in life you felt the most
worthless as a human being
your highest purpose your greatest joy
and satisfaction will come from helping
people who are currently feeling the way
that you felt who are currently facing
that situation that you are in that you
hated the thing that you would never
wish upon anybody else in the world lots
of people are going through that thing
and if you can step in and help those
people that's going to be so filling up
your soul I can't even explain it to you
for me my one word is believe that's my
who my why is I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur I hated my life I was
struggling with making 300 a month I
felt worthless as a human I felt like I
was bringing no value to the world and
that was massively frustrating I felt
alone and I didn't know what to do
that's why I love helping entrepreneurs
I love believing in entrepreneurs why
entrepreneurs could be anybody I could
believe in anybody believe is at the
core of who I am it's my one word most
important core value but I could be
believe it in anybody and I do and I
love it but entrepreneurs hold that
special spot for me and the startup
entrepreneurs not the ones who are
already making tons of money I love them
too but I resonate Nate so much more
with the startup entrepreneurs because I
remember what it's like eating at
McDonald's and only being able to afford
french fries instead of an entire meal
so your why your purpose comes from your
pain figure out what that most painful
moment was for you and it's hard because
entrepreneurs we like looking and being
optimistic and looking forward and being
positive but it's in that pain that your
answer actually is find out what that
most painful moment was your why your
highest purpose will come from helping
people who are currently facing that
right now and then step three is the how
so how are you going to do it there's a
lot of ways you can help people who are
in that situation so for me break it
down the who is my one word is believe
the wise helping entrepreneurs purpose
comes from my pain the how do I help
entrepreneurs how do I believe in
entrepreneurs there's a ton of ways that
I could be believing in entrepreneurs so
the example I use of is if you are
moving your office and you need my help
to rent a moving truck and to help you
carry your desks and all of that stuff I
love the end result of it I love that
now you have this great office where you
can build a business and have it
flourish and I'll probably say yes to
helping you do that especially if you're
a close friend but I don't love the
process of moving I don't love the
process of packing up boxes I don't love
the process of setting up cables and
wires and putting together an office I
don't love that process I love the
result because I'm believing in
entrepreneurs but I don't know the
process and so if you write down you
make a list of all the things that you
do the activities that you have done
that you've enjoyed the result make a
list of 10 to 15 times you've helped
somebody with that same pain that you
had growing up
you've helped them and you enjoyed the
end result and then Circle the wines
where you enjoyed the process as well
because when you can enjoy the process
and you enjoy the end result it's a home
run
now you've found your higher purpose now
you have clarity now you have a plan
that's the point of the purpose planner
step one you figure out your who your
one word most important core value step
two you figure out your why your purpose
comes from your pain the thing that you
never want anybody to ever have to
experience again because it was so
painful for you and then step three is
the how the process you need to love the
process you figure out those three
things you are set for life if you woke
up and did the thing that made you feel
bold and Unstoppable and powerful and
confident every single day if you
started your day with that thing your
life would look dramatically different
one year from today compared to where
you currently are right now the problem
is most people wake up like an accident
most people they wake up they check
their phone and they're immediately
responding to other people's emergencies
and demands on your time you're not in
control you haven't decided to take
control of your day that your day is
important that your life is important
and you are going to take ownership of
it and so you need to block off the time
in the morning and maybe five minutes
maybe you need 15 maybe you need an hour
and a half whatever it is the thing that
makes you feel bold Unstoppable powerful
confident fill your cup every single day
because other people have demanded your
time and they won't fill your cup for
you you have to say this is my ownership
right here nobody's touching it I'm
taking charge
now that looks different for different
people how Oprah does it is different
than how I do it is different than how
Dwayne The Rock Johnson does it Dwayne
Johnson has to get his four hours of
workout in every day when he's working
on a movie set and he has to be in by
nine he'll wake up at four in the
morning so he can go work out for four
hours and then go back and and shower
and get ready for his movie so he's only
sleeping five hours a day when he's
doing movies I think that's crazy but to
him that's balance that's him filling
his cup that's him reminding himself of
what he's doing he loves working out
that's why I don't look like Dwayne The
Rock Johnson right there's a difference
between us I would rather sleep I would
rather do something else in the morning
and so we tend to look at what we're
doing against somebody else you tend to
look at Oprah and say well she's doing
it this way I need to do that Dwayne's
doing it this way I need to do that
Evan's doing it this way I need to do
that you judge yourself against other
people's routines and methods of filling
their cup and I think that's actually a
recipe for failure because you are not
that person because what works for them
is not going to be the exact same thing
that works for you here's the good news
you already know what fills your cup you
already know what makes you feel bold
and alive and full of momentum and
confidence you have had that happen to
you in the past you're just not living
there consistently you know what has
helped you feel full
but you're living there one percent of
the time and 99 of the time you spend
reacting to other people their demands
their emergencies their issues for your
time and so reverse engineer for
yourself when was the last time you felt
filled up motivated confident bold
excited what happened what were you
doing what led to that thing to happen
were you watching a video where you
listened to a podcast where you're
reading the book we're going to an event
a seminar were you outside you know I'm
sitting here on a swing here outside
where you're outside you need to get out
of nature do you need to meditate you
need to have a shower do you need to
dance to music like what's the thing
without judgment without caring if
anybody else has to do that thing maybe
you need to wake up every day and pet
your frog and that's the thing that
makes you feel amazing great do that
plan for it every single morning because
I guarantee you if you did the thing
that helped fill your cup that made you
feel bold and Unstoppable and confident
and Powerful if all you did was wake up
every day and did that thing
your life will be dramatically different
one year from today compared to where
you are right now you will not recognize
your life so please stop waking up like
an accident and put this into your
morning routine every single day
self-improvement is the answer to
whatever obstacle is staring you in the
face right now the only difference
between you and greatness is the
willingness to grow and improve it's not
Talent it's not smart it's the
willingness to improve yourself the
difference between you and Tony Robbins
is he has spent more time constantly
improving himself than most people on
the planet here's a guy who had multiple
fathers growing up had an abusive mother
who at 17 he had to run away from home
so he could become a janitor and never
go to college he then decided to be a
success he read 700 books in seven years
he studied under mentors like Jim Rohn
and today he's the founder or owner of
companies with over six billion dollars
in annual revenue if Tony Robbins can go
from being an abused janitor with no
college education to being one of the
most influential people in the world
why can't you the difference is he made
the investment to constantly improve
himself and you haven't yet at that
level so I look at my channel as an
example my YouTube channel and I've
learned so much over the past number of
years in confidence and growth and
abilities and skills by consuming the
content because I love the top 10 series
and the meant to me Series in the
espresso series I make them for me and
then I share them with you and
thankfully you guys like them too and I
can build a business off of it and keep
pumping out more content but it helps me
I've grown I've learned and one of the
biggest moments that helped me realize
how much I've learned is when I signed a
three-year deal with sage I was working
with Stephen Kelly who is the CEO and
every month we'd be on a call we'd be
doing a hangout on my YouTube channel
answering questions from people and I
was driving with my dad and I remember
him asking me how do you get the
confidence to be on a call with Stephen
Kelly and be seen as his equal all the
time and he wasn't asking me to put me
down he was asking me in genuine of he
was so happy for me that I was playing a
bigger game and it dawned on me that he
was right
the Evan of five years ago wouldn't have
been able to do that the Evan of five
years ago would have felt less than the
event of five years ago would have said
there's no way I'm capable of doing that
and then when I'd signed the deal I felt
like
it's great I love Stephen he's he's
amazing but I feel like I'm hanging out
with Oprah and Kanye and Steve Jobs and
Bill Gates and these super successful
people and they're infiltrating my brain
on a daily basis right a daily basis
three videos every single day on this
channel and so bit by bit it pulls me up
now I recognize I still have a long way
to go I still have so much more to learn
I still need to believe in myself even
more and every time I consume more
content it allows me to grow my comfort
zone a little bit a little bit a little
bit a little bit more and the funny
thing is all of these moments are are
little tiny incremental parts of your
growth I couldn't point you to one point
in my past where I said that was the
moment that I changed that was the
moment that I had more confidence but as
I studied every day every day every day
I could look back three months six
months a year and say wow I've really
changed I've really grown I've really
learned a lot but in the daily from
today to yesterday I'd say I didn't grow
it all and so sometimes when your
Journeys you're trying to learn and get
better you may feel like the growth is
really slow on a daily basis but if you
keep going you keep investing you keep
learning you keep seeking out mentors
you keep trying to get better and
improve not every day will be amazing
but if you try every day to get better
and learn I can guarantee you that in
three months six months one year when
you look back of the person you've
become compared to what you are right
now there'll be a big change and that's
because you continue to invest in
yourself the fastest way to grow is to
be around people who are doing what you
want to do period when you are around
people who are building and growing and
taking on the world and trying to
accomplish their dreams and you're in
that environment and you're learning
even just being around them it's going
to seep into you and get you motivated
and pumped up and fired up to go off and
chase your dreams most people have a
pretty crappy environment most people if
you're an entrepreneur most people they
don't have a bunch of entrepreneurs in
their family most people when they tell
their family and their friends what
they're doing they think they're crazy
they think that you shouldn't go off and
do that thing you should go and get a
safe normal typical job a lot of people
have a lot of negativity around them if
you are constantly surrounded by
negative people people bringing you down
it's really hard to be the one person
trying to go off and make a huge
difference and so that's you if that's
your situation then you need to change
your environment you need to be
surrounded by people who are like-minded
who are off chasing their goals and you
need to find some mentors let me give
some quick tips on how to do it because
if you don't you're never going to get
to where you want to go you won't
staying right now where you are needs to
be unacceptable needs to be unacceptable
because you will never get to the spot
that you want to be at if you stay
exactly where you are with the people in
the environment that you have around you
step number one is limit the exposure to
negativity that may mean you cut off
some friends just because your friends
in elementary school doesn't mean you
should still be friends now it doesn't
doesn't mean you have to be rude to them
you've just Grown Apart it's okay
it's okay it's great
you'll get new friends we need to limit
exposure to negative toxic people if
those are your parents you may not want
to completely eliminate them from your
life although for some people that's an
important step it may just mean cutting
off exposure to some topics if you know
that your friends or your parents talk
to them about your business ideas is
always going to lead to a fight
negativity just don't talk about it say
I don't want to talk about that and find
something positive that you can relate
to and talk about step one you have to
eliminate the negativity or limit
exposure to it in your life you will not
do great things if you are constantly
bombarded by negativity step number two
now you have to fill the void you got to
fill the void with positivity and so
that's reaching out that's joining
communities that's going to events
that's going to groups I'm on my tool
right now I'm in Albuquerque New Mexico
I'm doing an event tonight here in
Albuquerque and when people come
together who are like-minded all the
people who come to my events they're all
entrepreneurs and they all want to go
off and do something amazing and for a
lot of the people coming out they're the
only ones that they know who are off
trying to do something and now they meet
local people who are also similarly
minded you need to be around similarly
minded people and so check your local
city check your local groups see what's
happening see what's coming up get
involved get out of the house stop being
in your regular routine your your
current environment is not helping you
you need to get out and meet new people
and you may go to an event and meet only
one person that is potentially
like-minded amazing collect people I
like collecting good people collect them
I'll even be super awkward about it
almost intentionally where if I really
like somebody and we have a great
conversation
say you know what I really like you
um that sounds weird I'd like to find a
way to spend more time together like
maybe we meet up once a month for a
coffee and just talk about business
that's how you do it you just ask
and if you had that with four or five
different people then every week you're
meeting somebody on a regular basis who
fills you with positivity and energy and
so you have to go off and find those
people you have to say yes and go to
those events to meet to be around the
positive energy because what makes such
a big difference for you accomplishing
your big goals and then step number
three is get more mentors you need to
get mentors and one are aspirational
mentors and that's what I see through
what I do right through my content I
learn through the aspirational mentors I
learned from Kanye I learned from upon
me I learned from Oprah Winfrey I
learned from Mel Robbins I learn from
these people they make me better even
though I haven't met most of the people
that I profiled on my channel I learn
from them they make me better being
around them and their energy and their
wisdom gets me fired up seeing people
going off doing amazing things and I get
that three times a day on my channel
right like it will shift you it will if
you are watching content you may never
meet dandapani but if you're watching
his content if he inspires you and you
watch his content on a daily
it will shift you because now he's a
voice of positivity in your life and
then you can get real mentors as well
for those of you who are following my
path to 10 million subscribers series
I'm having people who I respect and look
up to coach me on different things that
I need to get better at who they'll
watch my stuff and say hey here this is
where you're great but here you suck you
got to get better at this thing you need
to make the decision to change your
environment you need to make the
decision that your life is important
that your mission is important to being
where you are right now is not
acceptable that you don't want to be
here again in a year like one year from
today you can't be in the same
environment you can't be around
negativity and toxicity every single day
you need to follow those steps you need
to remove the negativity from your life
you need to seek out positive energy and
be around people who build and lift you
up and you need to start seeking out
mentors whether they are face-to-face
mentors or aspirational mentors to help
you get to where you go your life is
important your mission is important you
need to start treating it as so life
isn't fair
the family you're born into the country
you're born into your religion your skin
color your gender there's a lot of very
real things that exist in this world a
lot of very real prejudices that hold
people back life isn't fair and chances
are you might not have the capital or
the education or the resources or the
parents or the family or the connections
or the right skin color or the right
gender or any of these things you might
not have it all lined up for you
perfectly and so the next step is then
what do you respond to
so yes you're right and then what
are you gonna be like what most people
do is they just complain they complain
that life isn't fair they complain that
they don't have the right circumstances
and then they become a victim of those
circumstances or are you going to take
the more difficult path the one of
taking personal responsibility personal
accountability and choosing excellence
and saying I'm gonna break free of this
mold I'm gonna break free of the
circumstances that were placed above me
I'm gonna set my own path I'm Gonna Make
the World better for myself and the
people around me I'm gonna choose
Excellence if you look at the people
that you love the people you look up to
the people that I profiled in this
channel whoever your heroes are Your
Role Models the people you aspire to be
chances are they came from nothing
chances are they had tons of odds
stacked against them and they chose
excellence and that's why they won look
at Michelle Obama her father was an
employee at a city water plant her
mother was a secretary and then once she
had kids was a stay-at-home mom so
Michelle Obama is the daughter of a city
water plant employee and secretary
turned stay-at-home mom and chances are
again whoever you look up to they have a
similar story it's very very very rare
and I've covered lots of these people I
may have covered more than anybody
online I've covered lots of successful
people it's very very very rare
that the son or daughter of a great
person goes on to do great things
themselves it's very rare that the kids
of people who've done amazing things go
on to do amazing things themselves it's
very rare it doesn't happen that often
and you might think that sounds crazy
these kids of super successful people
have everything lined up for them have
the money the education the resources
all the time in the world everything
handed them on silver platter it's so
easy for them to win
and that's why they don't win because
you win through the struggle because you
win by overcoming the odds because
that's how you develop Excellence by
going after the difficult things the
people who have an easy life never win
the people who have a hard life and
overcome and choose excellence and drive
daily and refuse to be a victim of those
circumstances those are the people who
ultimately win and so that's you right
now if you've you feel like the world is
unfair first of all you're right and
second there's a there's a bunch of
things that are stacked against you
then I would highly highly highly
encourage you
to surround yourself with the stories of
people who have made it with the stories
of people who look like you who have the
same background as you who have the same
circumstances as you who made it because
if they could make it then you can too
and most of the people that I profiled
most of the people who've done videos on
this channel look at their stories
chances are they came from a worse
upbringing than what you have right now
they had less than what you have right
now when they started and one of my
favorite stories is Oprah Winfrey and
she was so poor growing up you know she
grew up without parents she grew up
being abused by her family she grew up
with her grandmother who had no money
and put together dresses made out of
potato bags can you imagine going to
school in a potato bag that was sewn
into a dress like how the ridicule would
be from your classmates at school
wearing a potato bag as a dress to
school can you imagine that and look
what Oprah went on to do
are you gonna tell me that you have a
worse upbringing than what Oprah had
or any of your Heroes
spend the time don't look at how
Michelle Obama or Oprah Winfrey any of
these people make an extra million
dollars right now spend the time to look
at their backstory spend the time to
understand where they came from and when
they chose excellence and how it had a
massive difference and change of
trajectory of their life
because if they could do it you can too
you just have to decide
that one life isn't fair and that's okay
and two I'm gonna choose Excellence I'm
gonna stop being a victim of my
circumstances and I decide to make
things better for myself for my
community and for the people around me
[Music]
because you made it this morning video I
want to celebrate you most people start
and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there I'm here to serve I'm here to help
I'm trying to do something that good
what's the intention behind this thing
you're about to do if you're going to go
on stage what's the intention is the
intention to hurt somebody to screw
somebody over to lie to them to cheat no
hopefully not